hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
I am finally back from Las Vegas Nevada
which was where CES 2013 was held so
it's good to be back obviously I feel
like I'm the only one who didn't catch
some kind of flu there but I guess
that's good for me either way there was
a lot of stuff that I took videos of at
CES that I haven't uploaded that I
didn't show you guys yet stuff that's
just cool so if that was just there that
I feel like would be cool to show on
YouTube so without any further ado this
is sort of an extras slash highlights
video sort of a compilation of my
experience at CES obviously has a
one-man show it's kind of hard to go and
see everything but this is the things
that I got video of that I haven't shown
you guys yet so without me further ado
this is my highlight reel of CES 2013
this is a long video so sit back enjoy
and thanks for watching
alright so for those of you who don't
know CES stands for the Consumer
Electronics Show it happens every year
in January and it son las vegas and this
is the first year that i got to go and
there's always a massive convention
center filled with hundreds of thousands
of exhibitors with huge names like canon
and samsung and sony all the way down to
the smallest case manufacturer i mean
there's just a massive variety of things
to see also there was a ton of people
there more than a hundred thousand
people so it helped to be taught to be
able to find stuff if any way obviously
the first thing the most notable
surprise at CES was Nvidia's Tegra 4
based project shield portable gaming
console this is about as close as I
could get to the device right here I
couldn't actually pick it up and mess
around with it but judging by the
hands-on videos we've seen around
YouTube this thing looks pretty cool I'm
excited to see the price and hopefully
I'll get my hands on one when they ship
for a review video and then there was
Sony's Xperia Z this is one of those
devices that I made a dedicated video
about so that's linked down in the
description below the like button on
this video it's one of those flagship
phones coming to the United States on a
carrier this year with a 5-inch 1080p
display and this seems like one of the
latest smartphone trends it also has a
quad-core processor a 13 megapixel
camera and some other high-end specs
it's water-resistant it's really tough
and durable and it's handsome it looks
like a great looking device another
notable phone which actually showed on
video was the huawei ascend mate now
this guy obviously has a massive 6.1
inch 720p display which was the talk of
the place at the time but it kind of
blurs the line between smart phones and
big you know big smart phones and small
tablets but despite its size the mate is
actually not Wally's flagship phone
their flagship is the smaller H star
ascend d2 which has a 5-inch 1080p
display of course a higher resolution
camera has a better processor etc so
it's their real flagship and both of
these guys have that quirky me UE skin
on top of Android 4.1 jelly bean
another cool phone which is a surprise
was over in ZTE s both and this was a
ZTE grand s it sported yet another
5-inch 1080p display so that's obviously
a nice trend it also has a 13 megapixel
camera around the back two gigabytes of
RAM and a quad core processor and it's
running ZTE s own skin on top of Android
and this one doesn't actually look bad
at all it's just you know very different
from stock Android it's also available
in about a trillion and a half colors
it's a good-looking phone so if style is
your thing this grand s is probably
available in the color for you trust me
they have a lot of colors also yes I
spent some time with via boon to phone
running on the Samsung Galaxy Nexus in
Ubuntu booth I have super super high
hopes for this OS as you can probably
tell from my last video and from the
demos at CES it did look a little bit
smoother with the gestures and with the
swipe actions that they were using from
before CES so before CES it was a little
bit choppy now actually watching him go
through these things it looked pretty
good obviously they still have a long
way to go but it was good to see them on
demo at CES TVs were everywhere at CES
this was the big thing that we were
looking out for the big thing this year
was not 3d of course that was last year
but the big thing this year was 4k now
I'll stop there because I'm going to be
doing a video about just this settle all
the 4k stuff we're going to be seeing
soon but if you only get one thing out
of this video it's that 4k is amazing 4k
content on 4k displays like 4k
televisions it's just a tiny step below
like looking through a window it's
beautiful stuff so anyway stay tuned for
that video we're gonna have fun with
that one but yeah 4k TVs were everywhere
and wowing just about everyone who
walked past there were also quite a few
cameras
from the names like Canyon like I
mentioned earlier Sony Nikon and even
Samsung Samsung had another iteration of
their smart camera on display this one
with an interchangeable lens though I'm
not sure how many other lenses will fit
this mount but they do look similar to
the Samsung Galaxy camera so I'll do
want to try it out just to see if the
quality has improved Nikon of course had
a ton of their cameras on display and
Austin from Duncan through 303 had a
video about some of the new ones so I'll
link his video down below some of the
new point-and-shoots with really
top-notch so check that video out and
Nikon also had of course their Boston
DSLR and lenses on display some crazy
long prime lenses their high info forum
bridey's there were there so you can
just play around with them so they had
all this high-end stuff that's probably
out of the range of normal youtuber so I
just had to mess around check out this
burst shot from a full-frame
exactly so canon also have their boss
lineup on display with lenses so big
they made the 5d Mark 3 look compact
honestly but I mean they had everything
high-end up there so they have the c100
they have the thousands of dollar video
cameras this massive massive full-frame
cameras and it was fun to just mess
around with them I mean you can get a
whole lot more out of your image sensor
when you have just awesome glass on the
front of it so they had as much glass on
display as they could and I was fun to
try out with Canon and speaking of the
lenses check this out this is a Canon
600 millimeter lens cut in half you can
see to where the glass elements would be
inside the barrel of the lens the focus
ring is zoom ring how all the things
line up inside in the cross-section very
cool stuff and also Canon had this tiny
pocket camera on display this baby
little thing with a touchscreen on the
back that takes up the whole back it's
an articulating display everything about
it was tiny they call it the Canon
Powershot N and this is actually coming
to market super soon now something we're
also used to seeing at CES is ultrabooks
we all know you know this year was the
year of Windows 8 ultrabooks touchscreen
Windows 8 ultra books now I can never
really grasp the idea of a laptop having
a touchscreen considering just about
every single one I have every used has
wobbled when you touch it when you press
the screen it wobbles backwards it's
just a thing I don't know I don't use
the touchscreens on these laptops but
you know we'll see how these do and
there were plenty of ultra ebooks
running Windows 8 on display at the
Intel booth what else did we see let's
see cars we saw a lot of cars there was
car tech all over CES both inside the
cars and outside the cars they had Aston
Martin's dodge vipers Tesla Model S all
kinds of awesome cars and stuff with
neat technology in them and outside of
them and that's the reason that they're
here so something I learned was at the
gigantic magnificent 17 inch touchscreen
inside the Tesla Model S is powered by
NVIDIA and I'm a fan of car tech so all
this stuff was fun and pretty new to see
to me I've never seen this stuff in
person so yeah and then there was this
so I'll just let that sink in for a bit
pretty awesome now Blue Microphones was
also at CES and you guys may or may not
already know I've been using the blue
spark for all my videos for more than a
year now so blue has a new micro
debuting here it's called the Nessie
after the Loch Ness monsters name very
clever it has an articulating head a
built-in pop filter volume adjustments
on the stand which is neat and a
headphone jack out for what I assume is
live audio monitoring so this should
make a neat addition to their lineup it
comes in at a hundred bucks and it's
actually coming very soon and of course
CES is always full of all sorts of super
awkward super alpha prototypes that
almost mean nothing and kind of leave me
wondering when does this ship when is
this ship when is this ship when does
this ship and when does this wait what
and then there were the accessories
let's see a giant clip-on lens for
taking pictures on your iPad please
don't buy this some super high quality
games running on various devices and
various platforms thanks to Nvidia's
grid basically cloud gaming and very
cool indeed also some lady that thinks
everything is a touchscreen you I see
this kind of stuff at CES even way I got
to meet a lot of people youtubers
writers internet personalities too many
to name them all but CES was definitely
a great experience a special thanks to
James will and everyone over at mobile
nations and NVIDIA who made this trip
possible you guys are all awesome you
know who you are and I have dedicated
myself to going back to CES next year so
I can see hopefully more awesome stuff
in 2014 maybe I'll see you there too
either way thank you for watching this
super long video I made it for you guys
if you made it this far in the video
leave a comment about bacon thanks for
watching guys and I'll talk to you in
the next one